[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre nouveau rendez vous du
vendredi le 7-8 week-end on va parler
actualités mais aussi loisirs est
d'ailleurs voici les titres de ce
vendredi 8 janvier
l'actualité du jour c'est évidemment les
nouvelles annonces du gouvernement
pas de troisième confinement pour
l'instant mais pas non plus de
réouverture des lieux culturels ou
encore des restaurants nous ferons le
point avec notre journaliste astrid
bergère on parlera aussi cyclisme la
course au soleil le paris-nice passera
une nouvelle fois par les yvelines au
mois de mars
deux départs dans le département à saint
cyr l'école et à au moins vite sur mont
sion
nous accueillerons les deux maires de
ces communes enfin des idées de sorties
pour le week-end des bonnes résolutions
à prendre pour l'année 2000 21 avec des
exercices pour reprendre l'activité
physique ou encore une recette
diététique nos idées loisirs pour ce
week end et aussi le résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre le
premier ministre jean castex a pris la
parole jeudi soir pour annoncer des
nouvelles mesures contre le coc vide 19
et parler de la stratégie vaccinale
astrid bergère vous êtes avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
prise de parole alors ce discours était
bien évidemment très attendu finalement
jean castex a annoncé que la situation
sanitaire ne permettait pas de rouvrir
les ducs sont actuellement fermés les
lieux de culture cinémas théâtres musées
restent fermés clos jusqu'à au moins la
fin du mois du côté des stations de ski
le premier ministre a fixé un objectif
d'ouverture des remontées mécaniques
début février
quid des restaurants et des bars quand
elle si pour eux pour les restaurants et
les bars et bas la situation est encore
bien critique un pas de réouverture
avant au moins mi février
on écoute d'ailleurs la réaction d'un
restaurateur de montigny le bretonneux
ça va être extrêmement difficile pour
nous et pour beaucoup
je pense surtout aux restaurateurs qui
se sont installés depuis peu de temps
depuis un deux trois ans donc pour eux
ça va être très très dur pour nous aussi
donc ce qu'on attend surtout c'est une
date de réouverture c'est à dire une
visibilité tout le monde demande ça une
visibilité
là on fait des sauts de puce ou des
choses géant même de mort en moi sans
trop savoir ce qui va se passer le mois
suivant et les mesures économiques pour
ces secteurs sont bien évidemment
maintenus alors le couvre-feu à 20h déjà
en vigueur est maintenue au moins
jusqu'au 20 janvier
pour le moment les yvelines ne seraient
pas concernées par une avancée de ce
couvre-feu à 18 heures mais jean castex
annonce quand même que des nouvelles
mesures pourraient être prises dans les
prochains jours si la situation
sanitaire ne s'améliore pas et l'autre
point important eléonore c'est la
simplification des arrêts de travail
désormais six manades des symptômes ou
si on n'est qu'à contacter l'assurance
maladie est en capacité de délivrer un
certificat d'arrêt de travail immédiat
indemnisés et 100 jours de carence elle
mettra en place aussi un suivi
systématique avec deux ou trois appels
téléphoniques sur sept jours et alors du
coup qu'en est il de cette fameuse
campagne de vaccination est rien alors
les personnes en ehpad en unité de soins
de longue durée les personnes en
situation de handicap
hébergés dans des établissements
spécialisés les professionnels de santé
aides à domicile de plus de 50 ans
peuvent déjà se faire vacciner et le d
lundi 18 janvier les personnes âgées de
plus de 75 ans pour aussi être vaccinés
dans les nouveaux centres de vaccination
qui voit le jour les rendez vous se
prendront par internet ou par téléphone
à partir de jeudi prochain
merci astrid pour toutes ces précisions
l'actualité c'est aussi le parcours de
la célèbre course au soleil le paris
nice qui a été dévoilé mercredi dernier
à ce sujet nous accueillons ce ougna
broc maire de saint cyr l'école votre
commune va ouvrir le bal de cette
édition 2021 du paris-nice bonsoir
bonsoir c'est en effet un grand plaisir
que d'accourir d'accueillir cette course
qui est toujours un grand moment de
plaisir pour les les rides qui seront
traversés j'imagine et nous accueillons
également stéphane jeanne maire de
louiseville sur mon cyan commune qui
verra également le départ mais cette
fois-ci de la 2e étape de la course et
vous êtes aussi avec nous bonsoir sort
alors tout d'abord cette fameuse course
je le rappelle cyclistes se fera au mois
de mars prochain
c'est la deuxième année consécutive que
le paris nice passe par les yvelines est
ce que vous êtes content stéphane jeunes
vous qui attendiez je le sais depuis
longtemps que cette course se fasse dans
votre commune oui ben énormément content
fierté personnelle et puis veut ce soir
surtout le droit collectif pour notre
commune donc vous aurez déjà remercié
président du département qui a poussé à
la candidature de notre commune et et
christian prudhomme
le directeur d'aso qui a validé cette
candidature donc on va se faire une fois
collective de de recevoir cet événement
international pour une commune
à notre échelle de un peu plus de 1000
habitants ça va être un événement assez
exceptionnel surtout sur cette route on
n'organise plus rien depuis mois de
janvier l'année dernière donc j'espère
que la situation sanitaire va évoluer
dans le bon sens et qu'on va pouvoir
faire un beau départ de cette deuxième
étape de paris nice on l'espère en effet
le sentiment les sentiments même sont
partagés j'imagine par vous aussi sonia
bros évidemment en effet en remettre à
la folle département et à etsaut de nous
avoir sélectionné on va pas se cacher ça
faisait un petit moment candidater parce
que on sait à quel point c'est un moment
de joie partagée et je rejoins mon
collègue qui explique que bah oui ça
fait un an que nos événements sont
annulées que nous tentons d innovation
énorme pour essayer de mettre un le joie
dans nos villes et la course de vélo
c'est toujours quelque chose qui
assemble quelle que soit la pratique du
monde du sport vous vous retrouvez au
bord de la route et c'est toujours un
moment de fête partagée
alors on attend alors qu'elle va être
l'enjeu dans vos communes d'abord vous
stéphane jammet justement vous l'avez
rappelé votre commune c'est environ 1000
habitants est-ce que du coup dans une
petite commune comme la vôtre
quel est l'enjeu l'organisation et c'est
une course aussi importante
on a l'expérience parce qu'on organise
quand même annuellement une brocante qui
attire plusieurs milliers de personnes
donc avec 250 exposants 70 bénévoles
donc on s'est organisé un événement à à
ce niveau là on l'a c'est une découverte
pour nous donc on sait qu'on va pouvoir
compter sur les services du département
et dassault qui vont apporter toute leur
compétence et on sait si elles sont
nombreuses avec l'organisation du tour
de france donc on n'est pas inquiet on
s'est déjà réunie avec un vaisseau pour
préparer cette journée ces deux jours
que sa préparation commencera le
dimanche
et honnêtement je suis pas du tout
inquiet et
j'attends sereinement ce jour de départs
en sachant quand même qu'il va y avoir
deux mois de travail assez conséquent à
effectuer et surtout pensé à tout voilà
alors on dit souvent que le paris nice
et un petit tour de france c'est quand
même une course très célèbre qu'est ce
que cela représente pour vous cette
course sonia brooks écoutez d'abord
c'est un commandes de la joie du papa
j'en ai déjà parlé du retour ça
représente l'instrument
les équipes de la ville sont déjà sur le
coup j'ai encore ce matin voyez en
allant chercher ma baguette de pain je
croise des agents de la ville qui de
suite me dit même le maire madame le
maire mais quel est le parcours exact
tout le monde est sur le pont je crois
que c'est vraiment une course qui est
fédératrice à la fois le week-end
elle va passer ce dimanche 7 où il y
aura le départ mais à la fois dans la
préparation et c'est un moment où on
fait nos associations nous nos bénévoles
dans la ville comme nos services
travaillent sur un projet commun et
c'est une belle aventure alors dernière
question cette fois-ci pour vous de très
rapidement y aura-t-il des animations
sur votre commune ou en ville sur
mansion oui au niveau de notre école
primaire j'ai vu avec la directrice
avant-hier donc on en a parlé on va
mettre en place au niveau de notre
commune bien sûr il y aura aussi le
partenariat avec le département au
niveau du collège dont coup c'est que
d'ex bat thomas voeckler normalement
seraient conviés à les faire une
intervention que l'âge de gaillon où
vont les enfants de remise sur mansion
animations pour le public
avec la crise sanitaire j'imagine quand
même c'est compliqué on attendra pour
mettre ces animations en place on
attendra l'évolution de cette crise
sanitaire bien sûr et en fonction de
cette crise sanitaire qu'on verra ce
qu'on peut faire au mieux c'est vrai que
ça sera un peu handicapant
on va suivre cette évolution sanitaires
tous les jours et puis voir au fur et à
mesure ce qu'on pourra mettre ou ne pas
mettre en place afin d'animer le village
est de faire un bon départ et de votre
côté du coup sonia bros est ce qu'il y
aura des animations malgré la crise
sanitaire la pandémie nous avons bien
entendu penser à un village à l'endroit
du départ et on a on va dire à les deux
plans le plan au retrait sanitaires on
est tous dax lyon n'a plus de masquer
tout va bien et puis le plan 2 contre 1
avec une entrée et une sortie et un
nombre de personnes réduites dans les
activités mais en tous les cas on
tentera tant que faire se peut et on
sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas toujours
simple de maintenir une activité un
village de départ
merci sonia bros merci stéphane jeunes
d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
émission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine c'est mélanie
poké qui nous la résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
un nouveau coup dur pour le monde
culturel avec des chiffres de lakovic
toujours alarmant la date de réouverture
du 7 janvier des établissements et très
vite abandonnée par le gouvernement pas
de réouverture non plus pour les bars et
les restaurants
le gouvernement ne l'envisagent pas
avant mi février la campagne de
vaccination a débuté à saint quentin en
yvelines dix volontaires ont reçu la
première injection à l'unité de soins de
longue durée du centre hospitalier de
plaisir et son état d' à versailles ce
sont les professionnels de santé de plus
de 50 ans qui sont vaccinées au sein de
l'hôpital mignot un centre a aussi
ouvert le 7 janvier à poissy son
objectif vacciner 150 personnes par jour
le divorce est acté entre l'europe et le
royaume uni depuis le 1er janvier
plusieurs entreprises yvelinois sont
touchés plus de démarches
administratives pour les imports et les
exports et des délais de livraison
rallongés
les images viennent de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique mais ont marqué les
américains vivant dans les yvelines des
partisans de donald trump ont envahi le
capitole à washington le congrès
certifié les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
et après une semaine bien chargée quoi
de mieux que de se détendre le week-end
célia get on go nous propose ses idées
sorties et loisirs
[Applaudissements]
oh
merci eléonore cette semaine nous allons
parler des bonnes résolutions à prendre
pour l'année 2000 21
et qui dit bonne résolution dit souvent
reprendre une activité physique mais
après les fêtes difficile de se motiver
notre journaliste michael et demi
d'euros a testé pour nous quelques
exercices à faire pour reprendre plus ou
moins le sport en douceur
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose après les fêtes comment perdre du
poids je suis justement avec ses lilas
ses livres est coach sportive comment on
fait pour perdre du poids après les
fêtes moi j'ai pris entre un et deux kg
comment on fait comme beaucoup de
personnes vont joueur déjà
donc moi ce que je vous conseille c'est
de reprendre une alimentation équilibrée
à base de légumes de fruits et protéines
c'est la base de huy et de boire
beaucoup d'eau et puis aussi on va
s'occuper de relancer un peu le système
métabolique
parce que là ça s'est un peu ralentie et
en faisant notamment quelques abdos bien
bien ciblé le premier exercices
d'abdominaux c'est d'être sûr déjà de
savoir bien concentrer notre attention
ici pour que ça ne bouge pas lui demain
sur chaque cuisse pour nous inspirer et
en soufflant de toutes vos forces des
mains pousse dans les cuisses et les
cuisses résiste à inspirer relâcher la
pression
souffle à les voir et là on est en train
de travailler le transverse le muscles
profonds qui tient toutes les viscères
s'il y en a un travail et c'est celui ci
évoquait ensuite la jambe tendue les
pieds flex voilà inspire sans bouger et
expirez remonter les épaules a inspiré
retenez la descente très bien encore
soufflé montella on travaille les grands
droits depuis ici jusqu'en bas toute la
distance des grands jeux font bien loin
de moi une dernière fois et redescendez
la petit bonus alors attention des voix
déjà à l'allongement de la nuque ne
regarde pas les omoplates resserrer les
fessiers resserrer le nombril absorbé
j'ai inspiré en soufflant serre et le
ventre et décoller une jambe et reposé
en soufflant décoller l'autre jambe sans
bouger le bassin c'est un beau disposer
en soufflant des collines genre bah oui
ça c'est pour livrer costaud et dernière
fois et stop
[Musique]
comment une fois je dois faire cet
exercice sans ces exercices là au
quotidien ou par semaine ce serait bien
que ça devienne une routine et qui dit
routine dit quasiment quotidiens donc il
faut faire dix séances de répétition de
chaque exercice que je vous ai fait
faire et idéalement 3 à 4 fois par
semaine merci beaucoup merci à vous et
bonne année
foie gras champagne petits fours ou
encore chocolat fini les excès au mois
de janvier il faut reprendre son
alimentation en main avec une cuisine
des taxes démonstration avec la chef
sylvie gameplay qui vous propose une
salade légère et gourmande pour bien
démarrer l'année
un reportage de pierre gaubert
nous allons faire aujourd'hui une salade
vitaminé à base de carottes et d'orange
ce qui vous mettra du soleil dans
l'assiette on commence par éplucher 300
g de carottes et on les coupe en
tranches assez fine pour être le plus
léger possible si pluie sont à l'eau
avec un peu d'ail et d'huile d'olive on
va faire des petits bouillons pour
démarre un petit peu poche et puis après
on baisse le feu pour que sa cuisse à
petit bleu donc une quinzaine de minutes
au bout de 15 minutes
on vérifie lequel s'entendre avec la
pointe du couteau si elles sont tendres
pour les égoutte et ont fait réduire le
jus de cuisson qui restent
et pendant que ça qu on en profite pour
que les unes oranges à vif il ne faut
garder que la pulpe pour profiter au
maximum des vitamines
donc vous voyez là on a tous cette
albédo qu'on va enlever ainsi que le
destin elle est très épais on y va
largement et on suit la forme de
laurence jusqu'en bas pour assaisonner
c'est tout aussi simple on récupère le
jus d'orange et on y ajoute un peu de
sel de la fleur d'oranger et de la
cannelle si jamais vous trouvé ça un peu
léger pas de problème la chef a tout
prévu
alors cette recette que je vous propose
en salade aujourd'hui vous pouvez la
faire aussi en pl dans ce cas là vous
pouvez accompagner votre vos carottes
orange avec des coquilles saint jacques
ou un filet de poulet cuit à la vapeur
par exemple juste grillé comme ça ça
vous fait un plat complet ça y est c'est
près il n'ya plus qu'à dresser présenter
les carottes et l'oranje sur quelques
feuilles de salade sucrine saupoudrez de
cumin et ajouter du jus de citron
rien de mieux pour vous donner un bon
coup de fouet face au froid de l'hiver
et on rappelle que pour continuer la
détox tout au long de l'année
il suffit de manger des légumes de
saison réduire les matières grasses et
boire beaucoup d'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et nous recevons notre invité du jour
marie aline charrier bonjour bonjour
vous êtes directeur et conservateur du
musée départemental maurice denis à
saint germes en lait alors le musée est
actuellement fermé due à des travaux et
sa réouverture est prévue en avril 2021
vous pensez que ce sera possible vu le
contexte sanitaire vers nous sommes
résolument optimistes mais nous sommes
aussi prudent donc on prévoit en tout
cas on essaye de prévoir les choses au
maximum c'est à dire soit une
réouverture effectivement comme elle
serait en temps normal soit une
réouverture
voilà un peu plus contrainte de façon à
pouvoir accueillir le public le mieux
possible en espérant qu effectivement on
puisse rouvrir au début du mois d'avril
et en attendant vous avez mis en ligne
plus de 200 oeuvres sur le nouveau
portail donc des collections du musée 1
c'est bien ça tout à fait oui c'est un
portail qui a été lancé à l'occasion des
journées européennes du patrimoine en
septembre dernier
et donc à terme on pourra publier
l'intégralité de nos ingrat c'est à dire
à peu près 5000 oeuvres un peu plus de
5000 oeuvres
mais pour l'instant il ya 200 notices
d'autres qui sont en ligne avec des
visuels haute définition téléchargeables
et sur votre site internet on peut aussi
voir également une conférence spectacle
de 35 minutes sur la vie de maurice
denis
pourquoi avoir fait cette vidéo la
hanche et nous souhaitions puisque on
aurait dû rouvrir à l'automne 2000 2020
avec une double commémoration les 150
ans de la naissance de maurice denis et
les 40 ans du musée donc comme ce
n'était pas possible avec en partenariat
avec l'office de tourisme saint germain
boucles de seine nous avons créé une
interview imaginaire un entretien
imaginaire avec maurice denis donc c'est
cette vidéo 35 minutes qui était suivie
ensuite par une conférence zoom et des
échanges questions réponses avec le
public
ce qui nous a permis également de lancer
notre chaîne youtube donc musée
départemental maurice denis que nous
allons développer à l'avenir et donc est
justement est-ce que d'autres contenus
seront disponibles à venir sur votre
site internet tout à fait absolument que
ce soit des supports de communication
bien entendu mais pas que de véritable
contenu de médiation sous forme de
vidéos sur différents sur différentes
thématiques
le but étant de pouvoir faire vivre le
musée à la maison en tout cas le faire
vivre différemment que qu'en venant le
visiter sur place si ce n'est pas
possible
justement est ce que c'est important de
faire vivre le musée quand même malgré
tout malgré sa fermeture sur le site
internet
oui bien sûr comme tous les musées un
spine spécificité du musée maurice denis
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui les musées
sont encore fermés un sens sans savoir
réellement quand ils vont pouvoir ré
ouvrir donc c'est important de s'adapter
à la situation est effectivement
beaucoup de musées se sont engagées à
produire des contenus sur internet sur
les réseaux sociaux également peut-être
dernière question le monde de la culture
est malmené en ce moment maintenant à
cause de la crise sanitaire
qu'en pensez-vous vous en tant que
directeur de musée c'est une situation
qui est compliqué on peut on met dans la
balance de vies humaines et un bien-être
là il faut espérer pouvoir de nouveau
sortir de nouveau profiter de la vie le
compromis et l'équilibré toujours
difficile à atteindre
donc il faut arriver à faire les deux
préserver autant que possible
et puis avoir quand même un petit peu de
soleil dans notre existence un peu
d'optimisme
merci beaucoup marie aline charrier
d'avoir été avec nous
de votre invitation au revoir à war et
pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose deux idées de sorties pour ce
week end avec d'abord un parcours nature
capelli énigmes en forêt de sainte
apolline à plaisir l'idée est de
combiner course d'orientation et
découverte du patrimoine naturel de
parcours d'orientation sont proposés un
pour les adultes et l'autre pour les
enfants et puis une visioconférence
d'une heure et demie sera organisée par
l'office de tourisme de versailles
vendredi 8 janvier 2021 à 15 heures elle
traitera de la saga des descendants du
comte de toulouse dernier bâtard de
louis xiv jusqu'à la femme de philippe
égalité et le sais triste week end se
poursuit avec les avec eléonore qui va
nous parler de l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
cette semaine dans votre nouvelle
émission le 7-8 week-end du vendredi
vous retrouverez un journaliste de la
rédaction de tv 78 qui nous présente ce
qui fera la une la semaine prochaine
cette semaine patrice carmouze directeur
de l'information bonsoir bonsoir
aujourd'hui direction l'espace alors
absolument alors je vais vous dire que
la semaine prochaine on va parler du
vaccin on va parler de la vaccination va
parler du virus évidemment mais on va
prendre de la hauteur
parce que dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi prochain à une heure du matin
heure française depuis la californie va
être lancé un satellite alors pourquoi
ça concerne le territoire parce que dans
ce satellite via nano satellites tout
petit quai lequel la taille de rubik's
cube qui a été conçue financée par le
latmos le laboratoire atmosphères et
l'observation de l'atmosphère et de
l'espace qui est à guyancourt et ç'a eu
deux en deux ans trois ans de travail
pour mettre au point ce nano
satellite qui va avoir pour mission
d'observer les radiations de de la terre
fonctionnalités d'une observation plutôt
d'ordre environnemental
donc ça va être lancée voilà donc on va
peut être avoir d'ailleurs une soirée
spéciale au latmos dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi
on ira là film est d'ailleurs pour le
lancement de ce satellite alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est que dans
l'histoire de la conquête spatiale
ça a été souvent un enjeu politique
il ya eu la guerre froide les états unis
l'urss après la chine s'est mise
et aujourd'hui il ya un autre phénomène
qui est celui de la privatisation de la
conquête spatiale est plus en plus de
financements privés et d'ailleurs ce ce
micro et nano satellites est financé à
la fois alors il était conçu par le
public par le par le latmos qui sont des
chercheurs mais financé aussi par le par
le privé j'ai d'ailleurs philippe calcul
qui était le directeur adjoint du musée
qui est à l'origine de satellites nous
en parlent ça va être le cas dans lequel
va falloir travailler
le nano sa tête une très bonne
illustration pour ça puisque finalement
nous avons nous mêmes règles et
récupérer les fonds alors certains
publics mais beaucoup aussi privé
typiquement on embarque un capteur
médical d'une société qu'il a développée
pour le tester dans l'espace puisque
l'idée c'est que ce capteur pourrait
servir les astronautes
donc il faut le valider et spatiales
mais du coup là on a des fonds privés
donc on est en train déjà déjà notre
nano 7 et 9 nano sat avec un envoi vias
p 6 c'est déjà pu la filière habituelle
et donc on voit bien qu'on est on est on
est quand même dans une transformation
de la méthode et pour nous aussi
scientifique
on va devoir s'adapter a probablement
plus de collaboration public privé dans
le futur et vous pourrez retrouver
l'intégralité de cette interview dans le
vé y paie qui sortira lundi sur ta vie
78 points comme émission d'ailleurs que
vous avez présenté par brice était
exactement merci patrice pour cette
chronique c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission
merci de l'avoir suivi l'information
revient lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal
présenté par grégory canale et d'ici là
je souhaite une très bonne soirée un
très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]